Have you ever seen the toenails of your grandfather
and thought he might be a troll?
Those yellow, misshapen and brittle nails
tend to make small children cringe, and in
response, he wears knee high black socks with
sandals.
Known as Onychomycosis, this unshapely blemish
effects about 10% of the total population.
20% of people over 60, and 50% of people over
70 become victims.
So what’s happening here?
There can be several causes of your imperfect
nails.
The most common is a class of fungi known
as Dermatophytes.
Certain types of yeasts and nondermatophytic
molds are also a frequent cause.
Don’t think your nails are the only body
part that can be affected by dermatophytes.
When infecting the skin, they cause “ringworm”
or “tinea”.
They can also take up residence in your hair
and follicles and cause what is known as tinea
capitis.
Dermatophytes, and the disease processes they
cause, are quite unique in the world of living
organisms and parasites.
First, no living tissue is invaded by the
fungi.
Instead they colonize the dead layers of tissue
that have large amounts of a protein called
keratin.
Hair, skin, and nails all have large amounts
of keratin within them.
Secondly, even though no living tissue is
invaded, they can still illicit an allergic
and/or inflammatory response.
Thirdly, these types of fungi have evolved
to the point that they’re completely dependent
on human or animal infection for the survival
and propagation of their species.
To better understand how they cause our nails
to become so deformed, let’s first look
at how our nails grow and what they’re made
of.
toesOur nails consist of many different parts.
The part we can see is known as the nail plate.
Below the plate is the nail bed.
The white, half-moon shaped part, at the base
of the nail, is called the lunula (also known
as the distal matrix).
The tissue over the top of the matrix is called
the cuticle.
The nail itself is grown primarily from the
matrix (around 90%).
The matrix consists of epithelial cells that
grow and divide.
Epithelial cells are the most common type
of cells within the body, and are what make
up your skin and hair.
They primarily contain keratin.
Once they begin to reach the end of their
respective life cycles, the cells go through
a process called keratinization, also known
as cornification.
When the cell dies, it loses its nucleus and
other intracellular organelles.
What is left over is hardened keratin.
An enzyme known as Transglutaminase begins
to enclose the keratin in an insoluble mixture
of different proteins and fats.
The end result is the hard nails we use to
pick noses and give back scratches.
Keratin is the main food source, of sorts,
for dermatophytes.
Once the keratin rich cells are infected by
these fungi, they begin releasing sulfite.
Studies have shown that growth and proliferation
of dermatophytes is reliant on sulfite.
Keratins have a sulfur-containing amino acid
known as cysteine.
Cysteine bonds are what stabilizes keratin
and gives it a rigid structure.
These fungi use cysteine to produce sulfite.
Once the sulfite is produced, it clings to
cysteine bonds and thus the process is repeated.
The result is keratin that no longer has cysteine
and it becomes brittle, misshapen and generally
unsightly.
There are several things that can increase
your risk of having your nails infected by
these little demons of destruction, such as
diminished blood circulation, like in the
case of peripheral artery disease; slow growing
nails; injury to the nail; a weakened immune
system; a family history of fungal infections;
diabetes; and AIDS.
Age and gender are also contributing factors-
men tend to be more susceptible than women.
Environmental conditions like walking barefoot
in damp public places, humid or moist work
environments, and wearing socks and shoes
that prevent ventilation can also increase
your risk.
If you become one of the unlucky ones and
your nails propagate these petite parasites,
your treatment options depend on several factors.
As mentioned before, dermatophytes are the
most common cause, but there are other conditions
and fungi (like the yeast candida) that can
result in the same nail deformities.
Your doctor will most likely need to determine
the exact nature of your nail’s problem
before determining the treatment.
Once determined, if your infection is more
localized, then topical anti-fungal agents
like benzoic acid, Batrafin, or Nystatin can
be tried.
If your problem is more widespread, then oral
medications that target specific types of
fungi are usually prescribed.
In the end, if your nails begin to yellow
and you find yourself buying socks that match
your sandals, hopefully the knowledge that
half of people over 70 have the same problem
will ease your mind.
If it doesn’t, then go see your doctor and
have your nails tested for the exact type
of parasite invading them so you can potentially
eradicate them and the unsightly nails they
cause